okay welcome everyone to the last day so
you're live streaming out so today we're
live streaming in this morning Darwin
couldn't come he broke his toe and
sweaty and we debated and we thought we
could run an experiment to see how it
works so happy that he thought this top
because of interest to the workshop on
grounding so he will talk about
dependent drowning he has pioneered in
many ways so can you hear us Arvind yeah
you can thank you all right let's thank
the group for helping set this up yeah
boy thank you everybody
thanks again to the organizers for
inviting me and sorry that I can't be
there physically with you so this is a
bias subway on dependent rounding and
it's organized as follows you know so as
a sort of simple warm-up you see you
know how when you sample without
replacement you already get good tables
in fact there's a sort of forgotten sort
of happening that I do my new home and
then we will see three major topics rate
the last topic will kind of come back to
the second topic you know which is
grounding with just linear constraints
plus a wallop suppose we consider the
following problem we have the universe
of n elements and you want to simply K K
of them the standard method is you know
sample each element independently with
probability k over then the nice thing
is with independence of comments you get
a lot of tape mounds and you know
correlations are nice and so on but the
other method that may be more useful in
certain applications is to sample
exactly K elements so just the sample K
elements at random with
replacement so let X I and why I be the
indicators respect respectively in these
two methods for sampling element time
and suppose you look at a linear
combination of the excise let's posit X
and the same linear combination y of the
of the Y ice let's say the lips shapes
are non-negative linear combination now
we all know that X is itself like tail
because it's a sum of independent random
variables what about the tail of Y well
most of us also know about it but you
know there is this somewhat forgotten
result of heading which actually you
know pretty strong which says that so if
you have again this why is this
non-negative linear combination of these
dependent random variables weii then
happening actually shows that for any
convex and continuous F the expected
value of F Y is less than or equal to
the corresponding value for X right now
for instance if you take little f of X
to be an exponential function then
immediately you get your of type forms
for y because the classical turned off
everything bombs know that the
exponential the a of so if you use F to
be the exponential function then that's
what leads to the turn of hefting type
tail bombs right so so once again most
of us would know that you know in
sampling without replacement one gets
turn of repeating type things but
actually hefting has this more general
result so what does it say
so one perspective on this is the
following is that the wire is satisfied
the hard constraint that they add up to
K with probability 1 right and on the
other hand for example from what we saw
the previous life by happening we know
that they enjoy a good tail properties
as well so the motivating question for
us really would be the following suppose
we cannot do independent rounding under
various circumstances for instance if we
have to obey a hard constraint like you
know being an independent set either in
a particular Metroid
can we obey a few such structured
constraints while still enjoying many of
the
independence like concentration and
correlation box so this is the sort of
motivating question for us so that's
just a simple warmup
now let me go to the first part of the
talk so this is somewhat work of mine
from in retrospect you know I was not
aware of the work of a given spirit and
code then but really if so it's a
randomized version of they're very
powerful by paige rohrick degree so it
can take you know the following form so
you are given a sum of let's say
probabilities X I that Adam actually an
integer you know this thing the gravity
is not very important but you know so
let's say they are indeed L then we want
to round the little excise to binary
values capital X I such that the
following three properties are true the
first is a natural marginal preservation
property output case X I should we want
the probability lowercase exam the
second is that you need to preserve the
sole probability one like we saw in
sampling without replacement so with
probability one the upper tiers X I
should add to the lower case in size
until we want as strong and negative
correlation property as we can right now
the following will suffice and we'll
look at more sophisticated ones later
this is technically called the negative
cylinder property or informally negative
correlation which is essentially that if
you take any subset s of these bits then
the S of these random variables capital
X I and take any bit be the probability
that all these excise it will be as one
can kind of informally it just less than
or equal to the product of the chorus
part
so in probability this is called the
negative cylinder right informally again
it's a form of negative correlation then
so let's think about this problem so you
have given this is a little exercise
that had gone into each other the first
property is natural the second is you
know is already somewhat interesting and
dessert on sort of expects from the
second property although the third
property doesn't follow from the second
property to doesn't always invite three
but since you know these kind of balance
each other by adding up to L with
probability one you informally expect
that they're sort of negatively
different on each other now yes oh yeah
so what that paper of licensure gave a
randomized polynomial time algorithm to
do this rounding with satisfying all
these properties let's see an example
we'll see a basic example so by the way
once again you know personal perspective
about the three properties you know
preserving the biogenesis is of course
national and the sub preservation is
very is often very useful when you have
simple hard constraints like the budget
should be at most a certain value the
number of paths you need to route is at
least this much and so on and negative
cylinder oddly implies Chernoff bounds
not for arbitrary functions but for
non-negative combinations of the
exercise right so later again we will
see that with more powerful negative
dependence we can expect more right now
we are looking only at non-negative
linear combinations of the excites but
more generally we can ask for
concentration of you know arbitrary
structured functions f of the excise and
we look at those later but right now for
these simple sums there is some old work
of fantasy in myself for instance that
shows that negative cylinder already in
place turn off now let's see a simple
application of this although Chandra has
said to me a couple of weeks there were
some really nice recent work of his that
simplifies this quite a bit I talked
about in
the work from my paper here so it's the
same classical dragwon Thompson look and
distributing problem but now we have a
multipath routing problem and so you had
given some pairs of vertices in a graph
s 1 T 1 is 2 T 2 etc and for every in
sight he had pair and you're also for
each for each SI TI babe let's say
you're given a bundle p ID of sik
advance and among these you need to
choose all right parents separately for
every is likely a parent in order to
maximize you're going to minimize the
maximum congestion on any edge and as
usual the congestion on an edge is the
number of routing paths that you choose
that flow over that particular edge and
you want to do a min max here so this is
the standard Robin Thompson problem and
they case all the others are equal to
one single path routing and while here
if you want to do multipath routing the
point of this work is as we've seen the
next slide just by using this simple
dependent routing you get in fact the
exact same congestion bounds as does the
classical world so how does it work
very easy so write the standard LP for
the problem so suppose the bundle pi4
the SI TI failure has paths P I comma 1
VI comma 2 and so on so that's the
notation in the second line so P IJ is
the Jade path in the bundle P sub I and
we have a variable W for the congestion
and you want to minimize lip subjective
for every pair I'll choose exactly on at
our iPads and for every HD the total
load on it is at most W and the
the difference from integer multicom
oddity flow is that every X IJ has to be
at most one lecture it can't be an
arbitrary integer the main difference
from integer particularity flow is that
you really have to choose all right
distinct paths from the bundle p.m. read
that's the third constraint you know
that that's what makes the problem
interesting right so this is the natural
LP and now to be around with dependent
counting constraint number one so so you
know notice that the constraints Warner
completely
makes up for every I the variables in
coordinate uh you know for the different
eyes don't share variables here so for K
the eye you can look at constraint one
has an instance of different rounding
you are given these values little X IJ
that add up to an integer alright so we
can round them using dependent rounding
in order to get exactly our I of them to
be much and we do this separately and
independently for all the different eyes
so if we do that them constraint one is
satisfied with probability one and what
about constraint 2 now the point is if
you take any particular edge and look at
the left hand side of constraint number
two it's the sum it becomes to sum of
indicator random variables but these
indicators are either independent or
negatively different on each other so
over on the left hand side of constraint
number two for any particular HD is the
sum of really negative cylinder random
variables right therefore what we can
apply Chernov by this work of fantasy in
myself so so you cannot you can just
plug in the Chernoff bounds although
they're not independent and now we just
proceed
just like in Darwin Thompson right so
you look at the deviation above the LP
value W such that Chernov will say that
the probability of such a deviation we
are above the mean W the probability
probability of it is let's say at most
one over two M where m is the number of
edges in the graph and then just do a
union bound over all the images in the
graph so that the probability at least
half you get a certain condition value
which is the same as in norman Thompson
right so it takes a simple application
of different rounding so once again you
know you know when I definitely times
not aware of a gives we didn't go quite
a number of the original applications
inviting in the paper of mine all of
Rohan didn't cope at this one does not
appear right so it shows you the
usefulness of all the one hat satisfying
hard constraints line one and
simultaneously having something like the
negative a negative dependence property
which for now would just be the simple
negative cylinder property which is
sufficient to to get Chernoff bounds as
long as you're interested only in the
some of these handles okay so so this is
just a motivating application by the way
how do you do this different route it so
again so going back already so you're
given these little excise and you want
to route them to the upper case exercise
that satisfy these three properties
right so how do you do it it's actually
very simple just round them gradually
two at a time handing them two at a time
so here is a simple idea so again here
you're given these little excise that
add up to an integer L as always you
know once you once you round the next
set once it hits zero or one you don't
modify it and otherwise just do slow
rounding so how do you do it you handed
them two at a time so take any two yet
ungrounded random variables like this
xixj in this example so currently
they're the equal point seven point four
respectively right the point is you need
to preserve the subject so now this
point seven point four can be perturbed
to do is to preserve the sum either as
one comma zero point one or zero point
one come on water okay and the nice
thing is then you're making progress
because you're rounding at least one
coordinates now the point is there are
two choices just make the two choices
with the appropriate probabilities so
that the margin offs don't change in
expectations are solved so in this case
you can see that if you make the first
choice with probability 2/3 and the
second with probability 1/3 if you look
at the first coordinate zero point seven
with probability 2/3 it becomes one with
probability 1/3 it becomes zero point
one so it's expected value is the same
as before which is zero point seven and
similarly for point four so there is a
unique probability with which you can
sort of make these two choices such that
in expectation the value doesn't change
but once you have this then by a
straightforward induction the marginals
of preserve that's easy
the negative cylinder correlation just
takes a little more work so it's also
not very hard right so that this is just
the simple idea behind the paper
basically you know you gradually round
them and when any one variable hits zero
or one don't modify it and otherwise
take any two yet around it very means
and simplify them probabilistically in
one of two possible makes this off right
and just keep repeating until around
everybody okay so once again
you know it's really a randomized
version of piped opening what how to put
it in the complimentary fashion piped
rounding can be viewed as a dear
analyzation of such algorithms they are
the method of conditional probabilities
but as we see the sort of probabilistic
lengths in overtime you know has led to
interesting exceptions just by you know
which just like with the probabilistic
method you know in spirit it's in
principle it reduces to counting right
but you know the pinna we all know that
just the probabilistic lengths you know
Alexis develop interesting applications
and extensions and and we'll see some of
it so this is just basic dependent
counting for um was there a question ok
so no you just have one linear
constraint now I'm more disempower to
work of Canon escucha query file and
what rank which essentially boils down
to a collection of pairwise disjoint
constraints of this form but with some
additional wrinkles right so what it
shows the following so it's it's very
well note the same partition want to
maximize the monitor on some model
function subject to either lying in a
mate ride or being base of a metroid in
this case of course will be based on
mate right then the problem can be
approximated to within 1 minus 1 over D
which is best possible it generalizes a
variety of early admissions like max
coverage and so on right there are too
much said be but I'll go faster out the
first part because no it's not related
to what we've this this year the part
work by using some really elegant local
search
essentially what they show is that there
is a natural relaxation
one of the natural relaxation
relaxations for a sub-module function is
what is called the multi linear
extinction that that can be approximated
to optimal
that's the first part let's just think
that as a black box
right so and then you can view you can
the work is essentially using a
dependent rounding to round off part one
so and in this part there is no loss in
expectation therefore the total expected
loss is just one minus one over you
right so so let's forget about the
objective function right now so you have
given a point X in the metroid baseband
book so this notation n is the family of
its combinations of the indicators of
all the bases of meat right right so how
do not know it is inside this point
right now we are done if you are already
at the vertex and if we are not at a
vertex recall a very nice drop
properties of linear independence
properties of the type types that so for
instance you can see that louder we sing
mark that the following really nice
property is true so suppose you have an
out point and you look at the type
constraints and you take a linearly
independent basis for them then without
loss of generality you can assume that
on this joint sits in other words so for
instance if you look you know you can
always extract a linearly independent
you can always extract a basis for their
type constraints and then given Pollock
X which are of this for instance you
have some number of variables that add
up to some number of other variables add
up to 3 and so on so these can change
completely supported or have right-hand
side being integers and they are
supported or completely you know
disjoint sets pieces okay so essentially
once you have this you can treat each of
these separately but of course we are
inside a polytope we have to be careful
it's not as simple as of the earlier
rounding but the the Spiritist is the
same so let's you know
so you know let's focus on you know one
of these constraints say this X 6 + 6 9
into 10 writing into 3 right
so again suppose you have excited next
year as part of this constraint and
suppose again the points are on point
the difference now is you can't and you
may not always be able to entirely
around one of these variables to 1 or 0
right away because you may create a new
type constraint oil import of these
lengths so but of course what is true
till is that there are positive strictly
positive epsilon and Delta such that you
can either part of the you know the
points to the point seven point four by
plus epsilon minus epsilon or minus
Delta plus Delta such that you make
progress right so since that eater
either one of these coordinates hit 0
and 1 which is great oh one more
linearly independent stripe so you're
increasing the size of the basic spread
so it's so so of course you stop
whichever happens first right the point
is you still have these two distinct
choices but it's not a dead tie straight
right so we don't have the luxury to be
taking epsilon and Delta to be point 6
epsilon you know probabilities epsilon
in the module so in the first move point
7 plus epsilon point 4 minus epsilon
make it the proper Delta and the second
move making the probability proportional
to epsilon that 4 again of course they
expected change in any coordinate is 0
right and one can use this to prove that
by just with the same with similar ideas
as before you can get the negative cell
in the property and the other key
property that they use which I did not
mention so far is that every one of
these steps
none of them decreases the the mytilini
original extension upper case f of X and
expectation that they for an expectation
you lose nothing
just keep conducting and of course C
steps make gives you problems
so this is a polynomial time algorithms
because in each step you either round
one load variable or you able to have
linearly a basis of type sex so of
course within within a polynomial number
of steps you're done with you convenient
number of steps you're done so so this
is a perspective one can have on the
result which is really using the
structure of the type steps in the
matron polytope essentially you can sort
of reduce the problem to something like
pipe it out they got dependent all right
with the extra sort of complication that
epsilon-delta may not be too large but
that's still okay
so let's look at this certainly let me
summarize a part of what they do it's
not of course in this slide I summarized
what they do but is only a part of what
they do because I'm not talking about
the sub modular objective function so in
the language of different rounding what
you think that this is what they do give
it a point little eggs in a Metroid
basement or animated you can round it
and randomize polynomial time to an
integer in a solution such that first of
all the marginals are preserved and
second you get a Metroid base with
Schnauzer t1 right so with probability
one the rounded subset is indeed an
independent shift in your matrix and
third you get the negative surrender
property which is that once again for
any bit B and for every subset s of the
coordinates the probability that
everybody the subset takes on this value
is at most the corresponding value for
in the case of independent roni so this
is one perspective one can have on CCTV
on part of the world without you know if
we don't talk about the deck the fact
that they also handle the submodular
objective right so one question one can
ask is okay so we got the negative
cylinder property here can will get even
stronger negative difference as we see
this is not just a question of you know
of some mathematical interest but
towards the very end we will see that
you know the stronger the negative
correlation the better the
concentration properties we connect so
so so let's just absolutely ask this
question for matrix so given a point in
a major at 4 o'clock or animatron this
polytope can you round it to to an
independent set or a base of the metroid
such that the marginals are preserved
and such that you get even stronger
negative dependence properties between
the coordinates that turns out to be
possible so earlier this year there was
this work of tennis sing and Bishnoi
that I'll kind of summarize in one slide
there is an even stronger notion of
negative correlation than cylinder
negative association and that's that's
for a negative association and that says
the following so you have these x1
through xn right
suppose you have two two functions F and
G defined on subsets of these random
variables such that the two subsets are
disjoined so for example F depends on X
1 X 5 and X 6 and let's say G depends on
X 2 X 7 X 9 so they're supported on
disjoint subsets of the given random
variables and furthermore let's say both
are monotone increasing at both both are
more from decreasing right and negative
association is the property that for any
such monotone F and G the expected value
of f G is less than or equal to the
product of the few expectation so x1
through xn are said to be negatively
associated if for all monotone F and G
supported on disjoint subsets this
negative dependence property is true
okay so this is a stronger notion than
negative cylinder now note that so ya
know for instance the exercise need not
be binary so but you immediately get
take bombs for example 4 so if you look
at the second bullet item right it talks
about day bombs now the exercise need
not be binary stop my work with pine
cone icing on table bonds for the sum no
longer no longer hold of the X ice are
non-binding so suppose you have let's
say a non-negative linear combination of
the excise then since the exponential
function is monotone a very simple
induction immediately tells you that the
function that we care about
Chernov time bombs which is the left
hand side they expected value of the
product of e to the t ax i where T is
some real number by this negative we
immediately get this inequality it's
less than or equal to the product of the
expectations which of course makes
calculation is very simple and you know
again you know negative cylinder doesn't
hold here if the exercise have non mine
okay so so negative association if you
only are interested in sums immediately
gives you you know very quick you know
take bombs
why do it's a very powerful fact I I
don't think it's used as much as some
probably it can be for instance there is
some really nice work of the by Xie
dungeon that says the following its
Excel very useful fat if you have M bins
and you throw em pawns independently
independently but with arbitrary
individual distributions into the bins
and you look at the vector of all the
wind load effects or so l1 is the number
of boss that fell in bin one and two is
the number that fell in bin 2 and so on
then this vector of random variables is
actually negatively associated in fact I
had the opportunity to use this in some
since some work several years ago so
negative association is a very powerful
property and what parents sing and
Vishnoi show is that in fact you can get
a stronger version than what we saw in
the previous slide let me go to the
previous slide in the previous slide
regard the CCP by rounding that gives
negative selected in fact you get
negative association and you know they
show that by using the Lovett make a
render at render what let me not go into
the details you actually get negative
association for Metroid pointers so it's
a very interesting useful thing to keep
in mind and when it come to the very end
I kind of look at even further
generalizations even strong with
negative association properties and why
they are useful improving concentration
bounds when you are interested in
functions of the excise that are not
just sums more more more structured
functions you can get significant K
pounds for it so so please keep this in
mind I will now switch to the second
part of the talk which moves on to
bipartite graphs and matron intersection
so far we generally spoke that the
primary
we were a Christian home was a linear
constraint or pairwise disjoint linear
constraints let's uh make this setup a
little more complicated now so so once
again so there's this other work that I
did which in the back also is a
randomized version of might be rounding
of extra pipe is rounding was awful
enough to capture a lot of these but in
deterministic language let me now just
explicit in probabilistic language and
after discussing it you see what I say
in the last line which is the really the
earlier dependent rounding that we saw
it's just this what we see on the slide
but applied to a very simple our graph
is a bipartite graph with just one
vertex on one side so what's the
rounding problem here
so now you've given a bipartite graph
and you're given a value X IJ let's say
between 0 and 1 for every edge otherwise
just subtract the integer part so what
we want now is to round each little X IJ
to uppercase X IJ that is binary in
grant wise polynomial time such that
once again the margin of the preserve
that's bullet number 1 and the second is
the analog of preserving the sum we now
preserve the summit every vertex right
at every vertex if you look at all the
edges and count the sum of the capital X
IJ is they add up to the small X IJ is
up to taking the floor or ceiling right
so if the original sum was four point
seven the new someone before a fight and
then again you want negative cylinder
but negative asking for negative see
little bit for arbitrary subsets is
impossible so what we ask is there at
every vertex you look again at a vertex
v that's the third property you look at
the edges incident at the vertex then
they that tuple of random variables
corresponding to edges incident at i
satisfy the negative syllable count so
once again like I said this is you can
view this as an itemization of five
accounting but as we will see in the
very next slide the probabilistic view
is very helpful okay and yes so simple
exercises to is to observe that the very
first dependent round obispo quote is
actually just what we see on the slide
applied the Stagner okay
so so so so I'll give you a moment to
digest this line so once again this is
possible in by a simple extension of the
previous idea is it in randomized
polynomial time okay so but the
probabilistic news is very helpful and
very recent from last year of nickel
Munsell ola Spencer and myself on
scheduling to minimize weighted
completion time so which is which
extends the negative correlation certain
types of guaranteed negative Commission
what do we mean here so once again
recall the basic setup with a bipartite
graph G and the value little X X IJ for
every edge so what we show is that for
certain types of these in input
instances you can guarantee almost all
the properties of G K G appears of the
previous slide and unfertile more for
every one vertex J on the right hand
side we write for every J and B and for
many pairs of edges I 1 comma J and I 2
comma J that are incident at J it is not
just true so now is look at the
inequality so the in the earlier
inequality in negative cylinder you will
not have the 1 minus Zeta on minus Zeta
graph right so think of Cetus is zero
point one right so what this is saying
is that the probability that these two
edges are both selected is less than or
equal to 0.9 times the product of the
two probability so in other words you
don't just have negative correlation but
a guaranteed amount of negative
correlation in the form of the Zeta
which is some tiny but positive constant
so you know so once again it's the
probabilistic interpretation which kind
of lends itself to extensions like this
and I won't go with the proof of this
but what happening there's a sort of
motivating application is to beat the
well-known three halves approximation
for a certain scheduling problem which
is to schedule of unrelated federal
machines to minimize mated completion
time we could improve it by a small
constant and there's been further
significant progress by in work of XI Li
that you'd have heard
heard about it this week so you know so
what I wanted to mention is that Shoji
capias can be used as a framework for
some of these let me now show you in a
little more detail under such
application this is of course stochastic
matching and this is work of early
history in Nagarajan and rundown okay so
in case you haven't seen stochastic
matching it's a very interesting variant
of mine whose complexity is actually not
understood it's not known of this
problem this problem is in P or is
np-hard which is very interesting and
you know in the best approximability nah
none of it is known so it's a very
interesting problem so going into the
motivations let me define the problem so
you had given a graph every inches and
non-negative weight and the probability
P that's the first bullet second every
vertex B has a non negative integral
patients let's call it TV and the
stochastic city the problem comes
because every edge is present
independently with the given known
probability PE but you know to Detective
the H is actually present we have to
explicitly probe for it and the next
bullet item is interesting if they chose
to probe for the HEA I'm actually it
turns out to be present then we have to
add it to our magic so we start with the
empty matching we increment reacted by
probing edges if you sir if you probe
for a certain H and if it's if it
happens to be present you have to add it
in matching and of course then delete
all the incident edges right and finally
where does the patience player oh so at
any vertex V the incident edges can be
probed at most TVs and then the vertex V
loses its patience beyond the time right
so so these are the constraints of the
problem and of course what you are
desire is a match a matching of maximum
expected weight so all it's down to in
what order may be adaptively or non
adaptively will you probe the edges in
order to maximize the expected weight of
the matching constructed of course
Thanks when we say expected weight we me
Frank will be mean that the randomness
is both over the stochastic city in the
airport and
okay so this is the problem I'll give
you a moment to stare at the problem and
once again it's very interesting it's
it's complexity is very much not
understood here for such a basic
sounding problem even if you drop the
patience constraint and so on I don't
think you know the complexity is not
okay so what these are conceived is a
1/4 approximation for this for bipartite
graphs they get other results as well
and some of these results have been
include upon but the algorithm can be
very sort of succinctly described using
different rounding so I thought it would
be a nice example to show you ok so this
is the problem and they gonna focus on
bipartite graphs and once you have a
bipartite graph you can naturally run
the dependent routing that we just saw a
couple of slides ago so so here is what
we'll do
so let's first write the natural MP by
the way the interesting thing is in this
MP you know you an integral random
variable at an internal variable and
relax it to her to a fraction of one but
really the MP naturally works with only
fractional values so so the natural
benchmark can be is the following so
imagine an optimal probing algorithm
it'll prove HT with some probability
high probability could be binary but it
could also be fractional so let X C do
not the sort of probing probability of
an optimal error rate then the
constraints are more or less
straightforward and of course I wrote
the constraint 0 XE less than or equal
to 1 not in this list but towards the
end okay so this is yes so if you stare
at it the first is the matching
constraint the second is the patient's
constraint and subject to these you want
to maximize the the expected weight of
the matching that you that you that you
construct so you can easily see that
this is a valid relaxation now know so
solve this simply to find an X and not
forget these constraints and since the
graph is bipartite the algorithm will go
ahead and run gk PSMs ok so forget these
constraints at this point but the
constraints hybrid depends
family fine those are precise precisely
the constraints that are reserved with
probability 1 by G K Pearson so let me
just go up like two three stripes yes
please
so this doesn't seem to allow adaptive
sampling right this is just a relaxation
this is just a relaxing shut what is
your decision to sample an edge depends
on what you saw for previous edges
sure yep so so yeah so this you know
this LP I'm not claiming that it's an
optimal I all unclaimed it is it's a
relaxation that's a guess so I mean how
to model adaptivity all that is very
interesting yeah what's the power of
adaptability which is not an activity
those are very interesting questions p
exe is the probability that you probe XE
and that the edges present rank in which
case since you're supposed to put the
edge in here in your matching term in
line number trees indeed you need
relaxation
thank you so so what's in it now so the
algorithm is going to be there algorithm
is you you solve this relaxation and
forget these constraints and just run
gkp is on this vector little X and if I
go a few slides up look at the second
look at the second self-preservation
constraint so the saw is preserved at
every vertex right up to floor or
ceiling so I'm with probability one so
coming back to our slide right coming
back to our slide if you run G key
appears then the constraints in free
file will be satisfied with probability
one plane so what G key fears will give
you will give you is a subset of edges
that satisfy v with probability 1 so you
don't need to worry about violating the
patience of a vertex and now what you do
is once you get this subset of edges
broke them in random order basically and
you know with some amount of analysis
where the neck
correlation is important they prove that
finally the probability that HD is Pro
is at least a head that gives you the
the for approximation okay so I haven't
given you really any proof but just to
give you a simple idea of how these
kinds of you know different rounding
frameworks can be used yeah please do
stop me if you have questions so let me
yeah so what about further you know how
much can we go beyond this deity a
standard thing there is you know one
such significant work of jQuery
quadratic and inclusion which goes
significantly beyond and there is a
really nice and ammeter gamma here that
I'd like you to sort of keep in mind
okay so if you should feel the producers
in particular for non-white non
bipartite matching etcetera also only
one meter intersection
what if the results they shows the
following so suppose you have given you
Metroid's over the same ground set you
you have a point
XC that lies in the in the in the polity
over both made rights in other words it
likes is the main intersection electrons
so they prove that any such fault so and
then you have given a parameter gamma
that cannot be 0 think of it as a small
positive parameter you can slit legs you
can round it to an uppercase X right
unfortunately you have to do
killing down you know cameras 0.01 you
have to scale down the by this tiny
value gamma so you still get most of it
1 minus gamma and then what we show is
that if you look at the second main the
main inequality they've laid this page
is that if you look at any non-negative
linear combination of these uppity as X
is together Chernov I bomb now what
commands is by doing the Chernoff bound
notice that there is a gamma the
experiment so if you look at the
right-hand side of this large deviation
bound
everything looks similar to Chernov
except it there is the gamma also
indexed on can I ask where the gamma can
be made 0 so one way to think about it
is you have a point in the
perfect matching for a couple for my
paragraph and you know perfect matching
let's thank the public matching
preserves has sharp consecration for any
linear in any non negativity combination
that's not what it's unfortunately not
blue for arbitrary my paragraphs an
arbitrary no weight functions so that is
why they have to shade it down a little
bit by gamma but then they get this very
strong plain wrong okay one can ask if
one can go beyond these I've come to
that in the very last time so one of my
points was to bring up what is known for
sharp concentration and there a variety
of grounding scenarios right shout
concentration is easy when you have
independence of other such nice things
or for example this shows is that under
these very challenging circumstances
okay so you get very good amounts but up
to you know the small scaling down trees
so they use a saw cutting technique that
they developed the phone along with you
martingale ideas in this paper now this
is the second part of the table so just
to summarize in the first part we saw
about a simple family of linear
constraints and since sophisticated
setting where you have a metric
particular you have a bank essentially
other bunch of visually different
streams the second part of the talk we
saw we've seen rounding in bipartite
problems and Portuguese equation so the
basic different rounding reserved the
some of the excitement with probability
one order to preserve a weighted linear
combination that's easy
actually there's really nothing to do
that's those are the first three buret
items so well you need to keep maintain
the weighted linear combination so when
you modify excite change just in strong
going perception on - I'm sorry just
we perceptional by AJ over a I am
similarly when you do that negative
Delta you weight it by the same factor
that's all and once again you have these
two options an epsilon and Delta
strictly positive and you take the first
option with probability proportional to
delta ii with probability proportional
to epsilon once again marginal
preservation and negative silat that are
easy to show now one minor wrinkle is
you may have to leave one variable
finally ungrounded but that's usually
done it you know you can handle it in
many different ways so that's not a
problem so I essentially this problem is
easy but let's make it you have two
significant competitions which are what
they are of mixed science but some
parents are positive some are negative
and then if you look at what the above
does so so for instance if a giraffe or
of opposite signs clearly when the above
procedure tries to round the bear xixj
it will actually positively coordinated
right because if you want to reserve xxi
minus HJ either have to increase further
degree of them so you you have to
necessarily positively for any time so
that's so actually what these
complications come up with certain
Facility Location problems again order
unlike in negative center where we are
only interested in a of X 3 X 5 or a or
1 minus X theta times 1 minus X 5 so
suppose you have mixed terms as you see
the second bullet item at the bottom
which is suppose you are interested in
the probability that X 3 is 1 X 5 is 0 X
8 is 1 and X 2 is 0 right
so you have mixed terms they're not all
the same bit but they could be a mixture
of both the bilges iran what so you know
without mentioning the facility location
context which is that it does appear in
some recent work with my current and
former students david harris from a
prince alert quadrant he develop a
certain method called symmetric
randomized imminent rounding timing this
the most important key word here is
randomized what do we mean by randomized
because dependent rounding is already at
of course excess we see this is the
problem we want to solve
okay so again
the first line you want to preserve the
sum over all IRP nxi but now the areas
could be of mixed science and
furthermore you're interested in
expected values like the one towards the
bottom of the slide where you have X 3
and X 8 but also 1 minus X 5 and 1 minus
X 2 so what do you do in such cases so
here is the simple intuition and then I
will give you the algorithm so some
final ideas is as follows first the
first is simple
you keep rounding gradually and of
course once once a variable is rounded
to 0 or 1 don't touch it and just like
we saw before you may have to leave some
variables rounded we will keep some
constant number of variables uncovered
right you think of this thing as
something like 1 over epsilon where
epsilon will be some added parameter
that's a small constant so you leave
like 1 over Epsilon variables unrounded
where epsilon is a small constant and
how do we handle the case where AI and
AJ are of opposite signs here is a
natural idea once again remember we are
only interested in the ungrounded fields
it's a throw out everything that's been
rounded to 0 one of the remaining
unbounded variables suppose there are 20
of them just pick a pair and the
probability of getting of choosing an
opposite sign Faris's this is at most
1/2 reckoned that will happen when the
imbalance just spent here if there are
10 positive and then negative guys then
if you pick a pair at random then the
probability that you pick of opposite
Sciences this is 1/2 busy and otherwise
so so with probability 1/2 at least you
pick the same a pair of the same sign
which is very good for us and also we
only make small moves as we see maybe in
the move by epsilon and Delta you won't
move aggressively but make small moves
and finally actually you know I don't
know if this is really necessary but it
makes the analysis simple we actually
you know essentially make Epsilon
the sea actually makes symmetric moves
but I think the most important we
breathe it's sort of proceeding randomly
by picking an ungrounded pair at random
and so let's make this a little more
precise now but I will do with roses
follows so once again first line you see
that the vector X without loss has
already strictly between 0 & 1
and you have this weight vector a which
doesn't have any zeros if there are
zeros that you can just count those
coordinates independently you can assume
without loss of generality that no a is
zero but otherwise they can be a big
science be a certain term right it's the
minimum over all my essentially this
data interesting thing that seems to
make the analysis work at least the way
we analyze it on global data so what do
we normally do if first pick up there
normally you pick a pair inj to do to to
modify and once you pick I enjoy that
payable suggests and it's not a little
part of this cutter but instead actually
what turns out to work is to pick one
global Delta which is the smallest by
which you can perturb any way to do that
is a minimum mode all right of how much
it can be very bite you know multiplied
by the magnitude of AI and then yeah and
then signal at random basically like I
said instead of an arbitrary pair which
is what all three DS work does pick a
random pair so that you have a decent
chance of picking the same sign and then
update them symmetrically with
probability 1/2 you move along ei minus
ZJ waited in some way and the remaining
probability you move in the opposite
direction the point is you still make
progress with decent probability so one
can easily prove that you make progress
with probability at least Omega of 1
over N in the sense that the probability
of rounding a variable in one step of
this is at least 2 Omega 1 over N right
and it's easy to see that this preserves
the marginals and it also preserves the
weighted sum right it preserves the
weight itself you know first you move
appropriately yeah I need you all that's
easy to see
and we'll business until like most II
variables are left to be rounded but he
again become as a large council so this
is the question yeah
thank you do the positive some and
negative some separately that won't work
we've tried that we tried that you know
that's you know at least you know our
analysis seems to break down to do so
Chandra's pointers yeah if you have
these 20 variables where you have these
you know you know a tender positive a
tender negative why not simplify the 10
positives together and then the 10
negatives it doesn't seem to especially
for you know so notice that we need
guarantees of this form for expectations
that have mixed like this so it doesn't
seem to help but you know I'm happy to
talk to you offline in quotes okay so so
furthermore yeah you want mixed terms
like this X 3 times 1 minus X 5 times X
8 times 1 minus X 10 and here is the
theorem the theorem is a little hard to
parse so please you know first of all
forget the second part of the theorem
right just to make the first bullet item
what we show is the following so if you
have any two disjoint index sets S&T the
expected value of the X are the product
of the excise all taken from s times the
product of 1 minus X J's on P then
ideally you know what what would be
great is if you can get the right-hand
side without the exponent P right but
that's too much transform right so so so
instead what we get this X 4 and D so
notice I'm sorry this exponent P but
notice that this P is like 1 minus
epsilon I and I mentioned it is like 1
over epsilon so this exponent P is like
1 minus epsilon we think of we think
epsilon is a small constantly C and this
is what we get for and upper bounds
expectation but we can also say thank
you miss and also get a lot right now
you get an exponent Q which is larger
than one necessarily right and you know
the second bullet is a little hard to
park so I'll just leave it like that
so so you get one of the answers to
children's mission is a partial answer
to Childress question is why not handed
the positive separately and then
negative separately notice one
interesting thing about this theorem the
magnitudes of the ai's plane go party
right if you look at the two that the
exponents P and Q have nothing to do
with the magnitudes of the AIS
themselves so I think we try it they're
doing positives first and doing negative
second you know maybe we didn't do as
good a job as we could but the exponents
P and used a record we're dependent on
the ratio of the maximum error to the
minimum penalty so but the the the
results here you get the exponents P and
Q have nothing to do the magnitudes of
the eyes themselves so I think that's
one partial answer at least in our
analysis we could not sort of eliminate
the dependence on the size of these
numbers basically why you got this
randomized algorithm P and Q P and Q
really just like 1 minus 1 minus epsilon
1 plus epsilon C and how do you prove
sitter
let's just give you a very simple idea
so once again let's look at only the
first first per attacker you want to
prove that that you want to do an upper
bound on the expectation in the left
hand side and remember the dagger to
does multiple rounding steps right
multiple small takes multiple start
small steps we want to prove something
for every step and then carry
and that's the following right so look
at please look at these three great
items the key point is that for the pink
that means that I mentioned in the last
four the exponent field that I mentioned
in the last slide anything is to show
that a randomized algorithm with me any
one step s what so please the first
bullet item there is an expected value
or quantity that we are really
interested in raised to the power of P
okay the key the key theorem is to show
that if you do one step of grounding as
we do then this quantity does not
increase right so that's the key thing
then that immediately implies by
inaction the second great item which is
that they also get a quantity that we
power of P is less than equal to what we
started off with in the beginning which
is the right-hand side of the second
button item right right so are now
finally of course what we care about is
less than or equal to what we care about
to the power of P because what we care
about this lies between 0 and 1 right so
so combining the second and third put
the key like the key property of any one
step in a srdr
is to prove that this this this what we
want raised to the P doesn't increase
vacation in any way but that's the hard
thing and similarly for the lower bound
we should have something raised to the Q
from wonder summarize this part what we
talked about was to extract the first
part of the talk by if I go back a few
slides I think whatever we want to
preserve the sum of the airway X I at
the very top where the air I spit of
mixed science look at the very bottom
you want also X mixed expectations and
in fact not just upper forms of this
expectations would also know mobs in
other words what we want is almost
independence you want to round the
excise to such that a excise preserve up
to keeping a constant number of
variables finally ungrounded subject I'd
such that finally the variables are
essentially almost independent right
they have not really almost independent
but there's something like they're
almost K wise independent as K increases
you know the the the quality of the
closeness to the independence decreases
but so essentially this like almost gave
us independence okay we're kids KKK can
even be large but then the quality of
the approximation is weak the quality of
the distance to the independence this is
unfortunately high so this is the third
part and like I said this naturally
comes up in certain types of facilities
location problems that we worked on I'll
skip those details and and conclude by
the way the conclusion will also say why
we care about some of these strong
negative dependence properties right so
anyway the first conclusion is that this
carefully introduced dependencies can be
a very useful tool independent from
being a very important mission is and
now as we saw from the work of parents
sing and Bishnoi one can go beyond CCTV
in getting even negative association for
metric for crops note that is something
even strong record strong really is that
possible unfortunately that's not
possible for all men rights that's
actually true from a classical work of
see mood and children of Masonic there
see mood and see moods are boys and I'm
sorry you know excuse me that I'm
blacking out so so flow from the seventy
so I actually be strong lately is not
possible now strongly is strongly
connected to analytical tools like the
unstable for no means which have you
know seen lots of applications in our
community now let's look at the third
bullet right elephant on muscle had this
very interesting of your question so so
please look at the third bullet most
muscles question was the following so
suppose you have x1 through xn that are
negatively
not necessarily binary suppose you have
an arbitrary function f of X with
written but it's Lipschitz let it slip
ships can you get good tail bounds right
now recall that if x1 through xn are
independent and F is Lipschitz then by
the classical azuma McDiarmid like
inequalities you get strong tail bonds
for it right for if F is arbitrary but
Lipschitz you know that by big time it
is an equality you know that you know
there are strong take bounds and these
have had numerous numerous applications
in combinatorial optimization right now
muscles conjecture was in fact suppose
you unfortunately don't have
independence but suppose you have
negative association his conjecture is
in fact that you get strong tails like
sub cows entails for arbitrary Lipschitz
functions that that's not known to be
true yet Pete Muntean fair is sure a
couple of years ago is that in fact if
if if the correlation is not just
negative association but something even
stronger which is the strongly property
then in fact then in fact one can get
sub those in things for arbitrary
Lipschitz functions again I think this
result is perhaps not as well-known in
the computer science community as it
should it's a very powerful result so
one very interesting or completion is in
general when our negative association
and even strong even stronger strongly
property possible in circumstances when
you simply cannot have independence I
will fight I'd close with two specific
questions one is like I said in the
chickadee water exactly or same setting
it will be very interesting to see in
what circumstances you can avoid scaling
down the one minus gamma it's a very
interesting open question and finally if
you recall the guaranteed negative
correlation from the work with one
celebs Wilson right we have to find if
certain specific circumstances come on
give general conditions under which such
such things will fall and stop you thank
you
[Applause]
questions okay then let's thank
government then you can ask them
questions off like
[Applause]